en un día como hoy suecia parece un
paraíso nórdico los países escandinavos
ocupan regularmente los primeros puestos
en cuanto a calidad de vida y felicidad
sin embargo no muy lejos de este popular
lugar de baño en malmö otra cara de
suecia se mostró cuando una joven madre
con su bebé en brazos fue alcanzada por
un disparo mientras el padre huía de las
balas que le apuntaban esta muerte
ocurrida en 2019 es sólo una de muchas
una lista de homicidios que se ha
descontrolado en 2021 y que sitúa a la
pacífica suecia a la cabeza de los
países europeos en asesinatos con armas
de fuego este año sólo en estocolmo se
han producido 94 tiroteos y 19
asesinatos
en las últimas semanas hemos tenido tres
asesinatos en esta pequeña zona ayer
junto a la piscina una persona fue
alcanzada en un intento de asesinato y
afortunadamente sobrevivió
esta es una zona en la que la gente está
harta de los tiroteos mortales
este barrio extensa en las afueras de la
capital en este caso los jóvenes de 19 y
21 años fueron asesinados el 16 de
agosto hoy la policía está llevando a
cabo la requisa de una banda de jóvenes
que poco después nos confesaron que
estaban cansados de este tipo de trato
denunciando el celo de la policía sin
embargo la policía parece haberse
quedado sin ideas unos refuerzos fueron
llamados a estocolmo en otros lugares
también se siente la necesidad los
atentados con explosivos también van en
aumento el 28 de septiembre unas 20
personas fueron hospitalizadas tras una
explosión en gotemburgo
ven las fotos muy bonitas como en
instagram es lo que la gente piensa que
eso es y luego viene al lado oscuro y
aquí hemos hecho de todo desde tráfico
internacional de drogas o tiroteos
ataques con cuchillo todo
es difícil hacer un seguimiento de las
cifras casi todos los días los
periódicos informan de tiroteos y
atentados el año pasado una niña de 12
años fue sorprendida en medio de un
tiroteo y asesinada cerca de una
gasolinera este año un hombre fue
asesinado a tiros mientras almorzaba en
un restaurante en gotemburgo un agente
de policía fue asesinado entre enero y
septiembre se produjeron
234 tiroteos en su opinión
al principio la gente reaccionó qué
demonios está pasando aquí
ahora forma parte de nuestra vida
cotidiana
la gente no piensa tanto en el tiroteo
de hoy porque sabe que probablemente
habrá otro mañana
mohamed nur perdió un amigo de la
infancia hace dos años en un tiroteo
pero cree que se podría encontrar una
solución en el sur en malmö en el barrio
de rosengart lugar de nacimiento de
zlatan ibrahimovic y a menudo símbolo de
la delincuencia en suecia
aquí ya no disparan a la gente por ahora
leen es gorg en junto con otros líderes
organiza sloot assiut o dejen de
disparar en sueco este programa ha
importado de eeuu e invita a los
miembros de las pandillas a reunirse con
la policía y les advierte de que su
grupo será blanco de ataques si disparan
a alguien o ponen una bomba les ofrece
una salida y muchas personas abandonan
estas pandillas porque ellos también
están cansados de los tiroteos
rozengardt es un buen barrio y tenemos
menos delincuencia que en muchos años
en 2017 solo en estocolmo se han
producido 65 tiroteos y 19 asesinatos
este año entre enero y agosto 12
disparos y una víctima mortal será que
schlüter hood está involucrado pero en
una europa sin fronteras un gran flujo
de armas cruza el puente que va de
dinamarca a malmö y llega a suecia para
seguir cobrándose vidas
es fácil conseguir armas en suecia
si es muy fácil
principalmente de países exsoviéticos
puede servir
el hecho es que con la unión europea
tenemos una verdadera frontera viernes
aquí en fíxose estocolmo una asociación
llamada pasos intenta reducir la demanda
de armas ayudando a los miembros de las
pandillas a abandonar su vida delictiva
con
todo el mundo anda ahora con un arma de
fuego porque quiere estar seguro en
lugar de estar en la cárcel durante un
año y seis meses y hacer lo que esta
gente dice vengan a vernos sigue
nuestros consejos y les prometo que
tomarán una vida mejor
en los suburbios la gente sólo quiere
ser tratada como cualquier otro
ciudadano sueco
yo le altere de davis
no quiero que los tiroteos que nos
afectan aquí en rosengard empiecen en
otras partes de suecia lerby tres discos
cuales cuadraba andrade a lo que quieras
que todos sientan que estos territorios
son también tierras suecas
y reaccionen con la misma fuerza en
cuanto a decisiones y opiniones y es
esta capacidad de respuesta a la que
quiero
ni un must y tucson sin embargo las
reacciones en suecia adoptan otras
formas tras convertirse en el tercer
partido del país en las elecciones de
2018 el partido de extrema derecha los
demócratas suecos centra ahora su
atención en la delincuencia y la
inmigración de cara a las elecciones del
año que viene creen que el aumento de
los tiroteos es el resultado de un
enfoque liberal de las fronteras en
suecia durante décadas un informe de
agosto pasado muestra que las personas
de origen extranjero tienen al menos el
doble de probabilidades de ser
sospechosas el gobierno de
centroizquierda refuta esta relación
entre ambos fenómenos mientras este
debate sigue y mantener a los jóvenes
alejados de las pandillas se ha
convertido en una cuestión urgente